today we are talking about Sleeping
Beauty in the form of the Sleeping
Beauty Paradox it goes as follows
Sleeping Beauty is going to be put to
sleep on a Sunday I should clarify
Sleeping Beauty has agreed to do this
and knows all of the details of the
experiment this is important Sleeping
Beauty is put to sleep on Sunday a coin
is then flipped if the coin is Tails we
are going to wake her up on Monday we
then ask her some questions and then
she's put back to sleep with some
Amnesia inducing drug so she has no
memory that she was ever awake this is
again very important in a setup and then
we also same thing wake her up on
Tuesday ask the same questions put back
to sleep and again she has no idea if
the coin was heads she's woken up on
Monday only ask questions perhaps with
the same animals you're in juicing jokes
thank you
Sleeping Beauty is put to sleep we flip
a coin if it's Tails we wake her up on
Monday ask her some questions put her
back to sleep she doesn't know it was
Monday she doesn't know what happened to
the coin she has no idea when she wakes
up what's going on
put back to sleep with no memory of that
incident she's woken up on Tuesday
same thing ask questions put back to
sleep has no idea it's Tuesday or what's
happened or if it was heads we just wake
her up the once
and then ask her the questions put her
back to sleep nothing happens on the
Tuesday and in both cases the experiment
ends on Wednesday so she's woken up and
she's free and she knows all of this
before the experiment begins so she is
aware that she may be woken up twice or
once depending on the outcome of the
flip of that coin to tell you what as a
recent father the idea of sleeping from
Sunday till Wednesday sounds lovely okay
sleeping braiding not sleeping beauty
anyway okay okay on Wednesday she's
woken up experiment ends okay now when I
say here ask questions there's a key
question that we're going to ask
Sleeping Beauty and the question is
we're going to ask her what does she
believe is the likelihood or the chance
for the probability that the coin was
ahead on the situation she is in at that
moment of having been woken up so
Sleeping Beauty has woken up on a Monday
or a Tuesday she has no idea she has
nothing that can help her figure out
which day it is there's no secret clock
or calendar she has no idea she's just
woken up and asked what do you think the
probability was that we got ahead on
that coin and of course the idea being
she could have been woken up on a Monday
and it could be the first of the tales
wake UPS it could be the Tuesday which
means it would have had to be Tails or
it could be the Monday but it could have
been the only wake up on the Monday but
because her memory is wiped after each
wake up she doesn't know if it's once or
twice or anything
so that's the question what's the
probability that the current was ahead
now there are two
both well-supported trains of thought as
to what the answer to this question is
and I'm sure everyone watching has their
own opinion right now of what they think
the probability is
well I'll try and figure it out she's
asked the question
either
if she asked the question when she wakes
up as well no not in the end on
Wednesday no no no no that's just okay
so she's asked the question either two
or three times
no she's asked the question either one
or two times yes
so
I reckon
oh let me think for a second
two thirds of the time
it was a
I was going to say two-thirds of the
time it was a tale but she's asked the
question so she's asked the question
twice on a Monday
and she's asked the question once on a
Tuesday but she's asked the question
less often on a Tuesday
so
I don't know
what was the probability that the coin
was ahead
yeah 50 50. well
ballad answer right option one it's
called the Harper approach to the
problem is literally I flipped a coin on
Sunday who cares when Sleeping Beauty
was woken up I flipped a Fair coin it's
a 50 50 chance the probability of it
being a head is a half because if I flip
a coin right now it's a half and the
coin was flipped before she was woken up
she doesn't learn any new information by
being woken up
so she just says okay I've learned
nothing new I can't apply my base
theorem conditional probability of
updating your hypothesis with new
information she hasn't learned anything
new Monty Hall hasn't told her anything
she did exactly but Sleeping Beauty has
no new information because of this sort
of waking up and not knowing anything
and the Amnesia effects of the drugs so
she has no new information therefore
it's the same as the probability always
was it's a half that is the argument for
the halfers in this problem there is
another potential answer and that is
that it's a probability of one-third the
third approach
so Sleeping Beauty does not know what
day she has woken up suppose we are
Sleeping Beauty and we can say okay well
let's assume it was a tails what can I
learn in that particular situation now
if we got a tails what does that tell us
that tells us we are going to be woken
up twice therefore when we are woken up
and asked this question
having assumed that it was the tails in
our own head we are like okay this could
be either Monday or Tuesday and they are
equally likely there's nothing to
distinguish between those cases so we
can say the probability of it being a
Monday
given it was Tails because we assumed it
was tails is therefore equal to the
probability of it being a Tuesday again
given I assumed it was a tail it's
equally likely it could be in one of
these two situations now we have law of
conditional probability tells us the
probability of a given B is the
probability of a intersect B divided by
the probability of B so we can apply
this here and say so this one is the
probability of Monday and Tails divided
by the probability of being tails and
this one is the probability of Tuesday
and Tails divided by the probability of
being Tails these two are equal so it
doesn't matter what's on the bottom
multiply through having assumed it was
Tails our conclusion we can draw is that
these two things are equal
because they're all on the same side of
the equation so we can say the
probability of Monday and Tails is equal
to the probability of Tuesday and Tails
okay now that was assuming that it was
tails what if we instead assume it is
Monday Sleeping Beauty wakes up has no
idea what's going on so she's like all
right well let's just assume it's a
Monday what can I learn about that
situation given I'm assuming it's a
Monday same kind of idea we could be
either this one the first wake up for
Tails or the only wake up for heads so
we've assumed it's a Monday so that
means the probability
of it being a Tails given it's Monday
this case
indistinguishable from this case the
probability of it being a heads given we
know it's Monday or we've assumed that
it's Monday same thing conditional
probability law
Tales of Monday well that's the
probability of Tails and
Monday divided by probability of being
Monday
this one is the probability of heads and
divided by probability of Monday these
two are recoil they both have the same
denominator so we ignore it so therefore
the probability of Tails and Monday
equals the probability of heads and
under now we have this equation and we
have this equation so we've got Monday
entails tails and Monday they're the
same thing in both cases it's a Monday
and Tails are split so this one's equal
to Tuesday entails and same thing is
also equal to heads on Monday so what
we've done here is actually shown that
these are like equal all three things
are the same and all three of them are
exactly case one case two in case three
of our original list we made some
assumptions did some conditional
probability and it allowed us to arrive
at the conclusion that all three of our
situations actually are equally likely
to occur the total probability
has to be one these are the three
possible events they are all equally
likely their total probability has to be
one it's the law of total probability
the only solution then is that each
individual event has a probability of
one-third
because they're all equally likely and
there's three of them
so we say Okay so the probability is a
third
for each situation
so it's it's a probability of a third
that it's a Monday and Tails are split
the probability it's a third that's a
Tuesday with Tails flipped and probably
a third that it was a Monday with heads
flipped so what's the probability that
the coin was heads
one in three one of the three situations
has a head they're all equally likely so
the probability of the coin was ahead
is a third and that is the third
argument no but there's a chance I think
there's a slight change there just the
last minute sang those three things are
equally likely is not so it's not the
same as saying is it likely the coin was
a tailor ahead because once the the coin
is flipped
a whole whole different paths are opened
up and different things are done and
it's those paths and things you're doing
the probability of not the coin itself
so we're we're not we're asking Sleeping
Beauty
not was it a head or a tail but which
sort of mashup combination of things
that happened
is playing out at the moment
this is okay I
both of these are valid arguments
both of these have supporting
mathematical statements using Bayesian
statistics using conditional probability
you can argue for both of them
in different ways both of them are
accepted by mathematicians that is why
it's a paradox because
it feels like you you can argue
successfully for either of them and you
can argue against either of them now
there is an interesting extension which
might help
to convince you at least Brady about the
one-third situation and that's called
the Rip Van Winkle extension to the
problem if we get a head Sleeping Beauty
is woken up once same rules same
experiment but just once if we flip and
get a tail Sleeping Beauty will be woken
up 999 consecutive times it is the same
setup as we had but instead of being
once for heads and twice for Tails it's
now 999 times big old sleep hence name
Rip Van Winkle now if you follow through
the third argument
or even if you just think about it if
you're in the position of Sleeping
Beauty if I wake up as Sleeping Beauty
there are 1 000 potential events or 1
000 potential situations I could be in
and in only one of those possible
situations did ahead come off on that
coin so if I'm a betting princess
I am definitely saying that I've got to
go with Tails here's here's the thing
though then that's what I mean about my
paths when you wake her up you're not
asking her
was it a head or a tale you were asking
her are you on the path that resulted
from ahead or are you on the path that
resulted from a tale because yes of
course it's more likely she's on the
path that resulted from a tale because
she gets woken up multiple times like if
I said to her every time you're asked
the question if you answer it correctly
I'm going to put a thousand dollars in
your bank account yeah you're gonna say
tails you will say tails because you're
woken up twice and you're woken up once
for heads so I agree if the question is
which pathway are you on yes I'm on the
tales pathway but if you ask when that
coin was tossed on Sunday while you're
asleep was it a head or a tail
well but does that not then come back to
the question of
so you could say which path are you on
and as you're saying it's like well
clearly I am on the Tails path so then
could I not then say okay so you're
saying it was much more likely that I
got a tails on that coin I.E the
probability that coin was a Tails no
it's more likely I'm on the path that
resulted from the tail okay yeah yeah
and I think
really glad you picked up on this
because that is kind of the the
philosophy extension to this problem so
I researching this like I first heard
about this one of my students in fact
and I just thought it was such a
brilliant Niche little problem that just
really gets you thinking and again both
Solutions are actually equally credible
from a mathematics standpoint but I
think it does come down to the sort of
like interpretation of what is it you
are actually asking Sleeping Beauty the
original problem was written up in April
2000 by Elga Elga and I think there the
original statement of the problem was
you ask Sleeping Beauty what is your
Credence that the coin was ahead or like
almost like what's your strength in
belief so it kind of you know maybe by
me using the word probability is but
that's kind of how it's interpreted in a
mathematical way but I think the
resolution of the Paradox does come from
that way of thinking about what are we
really asking Sleeping Beauty rather
than what is the probability
that the coin was a heads or a Tails
yeah Sleeping Beauty will be correct
more often if she says Tails exactly but
but she's given more chances to be
correct if it's a Tails as well like the
whole game is rigged in that way yeah
yeah okay so it feels as though here you
would have
probability of being a head you would
say Well only one in a thousand events
are going to be heads so I have like
very very small belief in heads so I'm
saying I think there was a one in one
thousand chance that the coin was ahead
even though it was a Fair coin which is
just quite hard to
paradox
this episode was brought to you by Jane
Street people who love puzzles and
paradoxes even more than we do Jane
Street's a global research-based trading
firm and they're looking for bright
curious people to join their teams
around the world a great way to start
could be one of their internship
programs check out this page on their
website their videos and podcasts
explaining more about it there are all
sorts of opportunities available in all
sorts of places typically an internship
can last maybe 10 to 12 weeks and you
don't have to be from a financial
background to do this in fact you could
be from any background James Street's
support number file because they love
our curious nature and they think the
sort of people who watch these videos
could be the right fit for them I'll put
a link in the video description so you
can check out more about their
internships jobs everything else
super exciting we think they're going to
be really common they're not the next
one is at sixteen thousand four hundred
and seventy so I'm definitely not
writing out 16 000 digits of pie that
that's that's a job for the viewer and
then after that we then jump up to 44
899. you've accelerated your speed has
changed with respect to time or you
decrease your speed you decelerated so
that's what the first term is going to
describe and then we also need the mass
you think of mass in this situation to
be a density